[Música]
soy consultor en desarrollo sustentable
y la micro recibió la agencia de
desarrollo ambiental acción planetas en
méxico y soy parte del equipo grupo
empresarial y místico sustenta es un
holding de empresas que consta de
desarrollar soluciones ecológicas y
comercio de una manera muy extraña a
mitad de toda la escuela y universidad
aumentaba
en término importante de estudiar en
islay con pasos sólidos académicos lo
uno comenzó muy extraño y voy a ver qué
algunos episodios
crecí en una familia tradicional clase
media-alta de alguna manera de joven no
tenía ningún problema
mi pensamiento para pensar entienda iba
a ser mi novia o que esté o hijo se pone
la mitad del vehículo y de alguna manera
estaba un poco superfluo esa motivación
de vida crecí en un confort y a los 17
años mi padre llegó a ser el director de
la empresa ford automotriz ya méxico
falleció una muerte trágica él se
suicidó obviamente eso collaço a toda la
familia media lugar en un 180 grados y
en esa experiencia de perdida estaba yo
tratando de usar alguna respuesta hice
un viaje aventura a los 17 años agarré
mis maletas de alaska en la última lista
de las audiciones ayudar ya que se llame
adoptado están pescando hoy el cangrejo
5 estuve un año trabajando estaba
expulsado es un viaje muy duro y no
tiene ese momento logré comprender la
fragilidad del ecosistema en el que
estamos porque me toca ver cómo llegan
los barcos llenos de peces y se
procesaban 365 días del año todo el año
o sea están acabando el maratón no puede
pasar me sirvió además para encontrarme
a mí mismo
los manuales de universidad
jefe de estudio no soy muy bueno para
las matemáticas no me gusta la física
converso internaciones con esa carrera
voy a andar por todo el planeta viajando
y me la voy a pasar 'limpios' con la
universidad la carrera pero siempre sigo
muy inquieto y algunas veces
rebelde no me gustaba estar mucho tiempo
de impermeable al segundo sin estudiar
el presidente de la sección de mi
carrera si eventos empecé a hacer unas
misiones vaya hacia las empresas
asiáticas son jóvenes mexicanos en fin
cuando me empecé a dar cuenta del poder
que tenía juliá le estaba impactando en
la vida real pues como que empecé a
hacer un plan de vida y el primer lugar
el momento de trabajar en el gobierno
crecimos la presidente municipal
necesitado de ser parte de un banco de
microcrédito que eso también generó
muchísima conciencia deportividad haber
llegada de la gente más necesitada de
ejemplo varios estados con muchas
carencias y en esa transición en un
horario estaba en la política en mi
gobierno me mandaban con los empresarios
para tenerles dinero y tener un banco
para prestar el dinero
a la gente y ahí con nosotros otro mundo
completamente diferente a los
empresarios buenos del país gente muy
poderosa
uno de esos invito a trabajar a una
inmobiliaria
inmobiliaria los años pero es interna me
decía tienes que irte por lo que
sentiste en las que tienes que defender
el planeta tienes que pelear por
preservar los recursos por cuida de las
especies y empiezo a utilizar las
ganancias de ningún área para hacer
viajes de investigación no tienen una
formación académica no estuviere
sustentable no estrella ni nada en esos
temas sin embargo con las relaciones a
las que ya tenía acceso puede empezar a
conectarme con organizaciones
ambientales psicológicas en el
continente americano
sus hijos incluso eran simples etcétera
y tuve la gran suerte de que tengo muy
buena memoria y leo las cosas y se me
quedan grabadas empecé a estudiar por mi
parte y empecé a estudiar
sustentabilidad
toda la fortuna de que la organización
de naciones unidas ni seleccionada hay
un año a la tarde
en cambio básicamente los locales del
país se colocan si no estábamos en un
mundo que empezaba al colapsarse y le
estoy hablando de hace más de 20 años
los ingresos de ese viaje de la tarde y
pues para que llegara completamente
claro que el 100 por ciento de abogados
mis mejores amigos y dije por favor
cierra la empresa porque a partir de hoy
me voy a dedicar al cien por ciento a
hacer una cuestión ambiental deje de
incordiar ya prácticamente secunda menos
delante una mano está sin recursos sin
dinero
hice una organización que hoy por hoy
esa acción planeta y eso muchísimo
trabajo sin embargo para mí trabajar
levantar con muchísimas ganas y recurso
llegó finalmente un rumbo académico me
tuve que prepararte de una maestría de
diplomados porque finalmente tenía que
saber de la parte técnica y la otra es
que requiere sencillo crear algo
completamente independiente prestando el
antártida me di cuenta que muchas de la
investigación de los científicos está de
alguna manera supeditada a un fondo de
alguna empresa a un corporativo que
cuando hacen esa investigación y si les
conviene o no sale a la luz esos
resultados de lo que ese estudio de
manera que yo quería estar dependiendo
de esos patrocinios
en consultoría y a la par pues la
historia de una mujer me caso muy
aventurero pero llevo algo de lo más
importante
las ballenas en el océano y así hacer mi
vida no tenía ni siquiera esa parte de
paz de unidad cuando nadie me dijera que
algo por primera vez y que no sabía lo
que no tenía y me dediqué a construir
una vida profesional relacionada al 100%
yo dije la quiero tocar y es lo que
estoy aprendiendo estoy viendo que
tenemos que cambiar es la primera vez
que hay estadísticas de población
consumiendo los recursos a este ritmo
acelerado diseñar que todo todos los
ecosistemas agua océanos aves reptiles
mamíferos y cosas una espera continuar
para que siga viviendo 2 que aprenderán
las cosas desde una experiencia personal
y no nada más lo platicará y luego un
libro si no fuera conmigo y empecé a
tener una agenda de viajes de
investigación vamos a áfrica inglaterra
concentración a mitad de físico es muy
larga dos siempre es una cuestión
extrema porque en el lugar del escenario
de la catástrofe natural para hacer los
estudios y ahora que lo veo respectiva
hacia atrás si me de cientos en platicó
un poco ver detuvo un de su etapa de
estos momentos de decisiones creo que
algo muy importante que me ayudó a tener
este plan de vida que para nuestro
planeado pero los viajes la pérdida que
sufren de joven la paternidad estoy
dedicado por cuidarme el ganado cuando
se hace más de 12 años eso de maestro
implicó hacer un cambio de vida
muy drástico
hasta cuándo regresará con él con ella
las tareas de además generar dinero y
además hacer investigación de los viajes
para que considera que cuando ya tenía
vacaciones el crítico dijo sin embargo
que es interesantísimo que sin haber
tenido una formación académica desde el
principio forma el que fui yo
resolviendo todo como si estaba
presentando unas ganancias simbólicas o
en esa voz interna en el corazón
comercial tienes que por ahí sin
importarle serían recursos o ya sea
presupuestos y se podría uno siempre
nunca tiré la toalla en mi familia tensa
venta violó con ganas mi familia siempre
fue como muy instrucciones muy formal y
muy del camino tradicional si yo te voy
a explicar muy grave ni vida de martín
es un bosque lleno de árboles y se va y
hay dos caminos el denunciada es el
camino por seguro con luz al final ni
bien diseñado trazado se ven yo sigo
hasta donde llegas
y ese es un camino continúa no hay
puentes
y por ahí me cuido de mí yo tengo
memoria camino y empecé a quitarle sus
contados de alguna medida fue crear de
un estudio académico de manera externa
estudiando por en cuenta que hay que
matarlo con la paternidad y eso me
encanta porque es lo que me mueve y me
motiva y ahora ver a mi hija grandes
ventanas sobre todo 47 90 establecido
pero me enorgullece mucho que creo que
estoy doblando la misión de vida que fue
enseñarle a través un ejemplo real
qué causas creo que los transmisiones de
milán tienen otro nivel de profundidad
nos vamos a expresar dinero estamos aquí
de paso nada más de los que pasen vernos
y dejar huella
y eso tiene que ver con cuidarnos cuidar
el lugar donde estamos y cuidar a todas
las especies como fin compartimos el
planeta no hace falta explicar lo vemos
día a día y tenemos las cuatro
estaciones del primer mundial y está
cambiando una dinámica cada década de
manera acelerada y pareciera que el
futuro está muy amenazado y creo que es
hora que todos desde en cualquier ámbito
del que se muevan le inventan un toque
de sustentabilidad de sus vidas tenemos
que ser más ecológicos y más conscientes
yo siempre por nuevo que tenemos que
mantener una inteligencia sustentable
aunque cambiar mis hábitos implica salir
de la zona de confort tengo que mover de
la aldea y ayer desgastarse en el
proceso no es tan fácil y además más
allá de la sierra del agua que recicla
no no no soy útil es una profundidad en
donde vives fue el impacto que consumes
que compras para que lo usas siempre
sólo comprando una chamarra buena sobre
una a comprarme 56 y estar en el
consumismo que demás mucho del problema
y luego analizar de fondo
nosotros impactamos en antártida
nosotros aquí en esta sala en las redes
generamos basura desprecio que tenga
hasta esos lugares tan alejados
encontrarán los primeros un plástico en
el estómago y las enormes de basura de
las grandes y hawai flotando en el
descenso de 20 cosas fuertes que a veces
hasta que no las están cerca tal vez no
lo compren si no te mueve porque después
difícilmente encontramos a la ballena
tirada está fuera de estacionamiento o
el oso polar y buscando comida del
infractor inside lugares tan remotos
pero cuando estás aquí lo es
urge es un llamado de atención creo que
todos somos parte de ese equipo lo
tenemos que cambiar y además mucho por
los civiles latas pero no es pasable
esta gente decidió el planeta y el
futuro de los jóvenes del desván o en el
futuro esa vista el presente todos de
todas las edades de todos los aspectos
de todos los países es impresionante que
después de tanto tiempo seguimos
divididas por culturas señores y nos
podemos poner de acuerdo entonces mi
llamado es que en alguna manera sólo con
mucha pasión y entiendo que esto es
urgente lo que sí hay otras veces es que
sea cual sea el camino que comenté lleva
a la ocupación nunca tienes la toalla y
mental de sustentabilidad vieras a veces
muchísimo su atención y espacio para mí
es un privilegio que ustedes tienen
organización abierta para que vemos que
en el momento que quieras me dedico sean
muchísima siguiente hay alianzas y
deshacer proyectos y hacer que las cosas
sucedan y gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]